well you see the numbers for tyonna will
be the tenth start of the year one and
three record the era just over five
brandon lau is ready tyona is ready
let's do it in the bronx first pitch is
caught on the line drive odor goes up to
get it one away
3-2
swing and a miss rosarina down on
strikes
the 2-1
high-fly ball right center
gardner makes the catch and taio retires
the raisin order one two three raise
nothing the new york yankees coming back
41 year old rich hill finishing up his
warm-up toss as you look at the numbers
his 11th start 3-2 record and a very
impressive 3.63
era
and he got one there three pitches
stanton is out on strike here's aaron
judge
hit shortly inside third and down the
left field line kicks off the sidewall
played out there by a rosarina and he
holds
judge to a hard single
that one is ripped to left field the
rosarina makes the play so the yankees
hit the ball hard three times
nothing to show for it no runs a hit one
man left we played one in the bronx
kirmar right back into the middle of
soft lighter that drops in
in front of gardner for a base hit
the raids have their second base runner
and their first hit
and dwayne you've got that lead off base
runner out there with good speed
here's marco
this fastball taking up the right side
that's going to wind up in the corner
kiermeier is going to hit third he'll be
waved to the plate
and he's going to score the reigns will
take a one-nothing lead
as
margaux hits that ball into the right
field corner for two bases
uh eric saying hey my bad is he made
that throw in there thinking maybe they
had a shot at kiermeier first the pitch
but that pitch right on the outside
corner maybe just off margaux great job
going with it down into the corner and
now will kiermeier be sent will the
yankees have a play here's the throw by
judge and that ball right off the glove
of odor he comes up with that and they
may have a chance for a play at the
plate as you see kiermeier going you'll
see it all play out here now they've got
a chance to make a play
nothing when it's off the top of the
glove and kiermeier
able to score
grounded to first nice play by lemayo
he'll take it himself moving to third is
margot
save to run with that play
well good hitting by lau here getting
the ball he can pull but a great play by
lemay you going to his left
comes up with it cleanly and then it's
going to be an easy play from there to
get the out at first base but you
mentioned michael the raise
scoring all these runs situational
hitting right here moving that runner
from second to third a productive out
popped up
and judge makes the play
for the final out one run two hits
one man left so as we go to the
top of the fourth raised with a one
nothing lead they are an austin meadow
swings at the first pitch into deep down
the right field line towards the corner
at the wall and it's gone into the front
row
in the home run porch
it new yankee stadium a homer for
meadows it's two-nothing rays
swing and a miss walls down on strikes
two
strike three
zunino down looking
but meadows hits the home run
fastball and that's drilled toward right
center field that's got some carry will
one hop the fence
gardner plays the carom and it's a
double for karemeyer
kevin kiermeier two for two
so here's a chance for rose arena over
two in the game today
that's a base hit driven through the
left side
and the rays will pick up that
additional run
a two out base hit gets the job done by
a rose arena dwayne these runs start to
get demoralized
i mean two outs
that ball stays up enough for rosa rayne
a great plate coverage able to get the
barrel all the way out there and pull it
into left field but you know you had a
quick start to this game by the pitchers
and then the raise
a run in the third
run in the fourth one in the fifth
he's on the move and he's gonna swipe
this one
in head first a stolen base number eight
on the year for randy rosarina i'll tell
you he picked a great pitch to run on
got a great jump and this play was not
even close
pitch breaking ball strike three call
just buckled them
and you got yours out number one here in
the fifth that's his second strikeout
stanton on three pitches in the first
and this one the curveball takes care of
higashiyoko
and the ground ball
third out at second out at first he got
the ground ball to third on the diving
stop by diaz down there it goes around
the horn five four three for the double
play
two down and here is anduhar pitch is
hit high in the air to right that ball
is high it is far it is gone
miguel and duhar
hits one into the right field seats oh
the do
can do and get miggy with it
he homers to right yankees are finally
on the board they trail three to one
three two again
and he gets the strikeout on the slider
all that hard stuff and he strikes him
out
3-2 slider to retire the side it'll be
his 16th game
so kion started licking peralta now
sessa to keep it right here
at 3-1 right now three to one
two outs top of the ninth inning
grounded to third hershella
[Music]
across the diamond and that will do it
cecil works at one two three
we go to the bottom of the night do the
yankees have a rally in their bones
jp fire eisen
enters the game
four outings since coming over from the
brewers
line drive
and he keeps it alive into the corner
odor rounds first he'll go to second a
two out double
so it's one and two only the second at
bad
new york has had with a runner in
scoring position today the other one
came
in the second inning
one and two the count two and duhar
and he got him this game is over a
strikeout of and duhar
and the rays
win this one it's a three to one final
and they continue their winning ways
their 22nd win of the month of may